positioning your bike correctly on the  road is really really important it's a  life-and-death kind of situation a lot  of the time  [Music]  particularly when it comes to following  other vehicles and creating enough  survival space in front of you so that  you have enough time and space to stop  safely  [Music]  so one of the things that we often do is  live is is we think that we can't bring  the car  this would've hit Pete do you think  there might have been a bit of a biker  patty in the middle squish  [Music]  so increase your following distance so  before 20 meters was big how about  double your bubble double that survival  space give yourself even more space and  time he's now got enough space hopefully  to stop  and Pete casually just checks his  mirrors uses his brakes nice and steady  nice and gentle Mike doesn't have to  slam on his brakes quite so hard and he  stops without squishing Pete  [Music]